Golf Channel NBC reporter play-by-play
host Golf Channel you got I saw Steve
interview Tiger Woods after round 1
yesterday on Golf Channel part of the
network's coverage throughout the
weekend you can catch to Eastern today
on Golf Channel and 3:00 Eastern on
Saturday and Sunday on NBC
Steve good morning some excitement there
with Tiger Woods fill us in well not
nearly as much excitement there was on
the bar at the hotel lobby that you are
not in a huge void at the Olympics Dan
you not being in a lobby bar to hold a
court every night for 23 straight nights
who was first team all lobby bar at the
Olympics in South Korea not even close
The Today Show people sneaky sneaky
party groups there the Today show people
they were on at 9 p.m. because of the
time changed 14 hours ahead so not 7
a.m. and they were in the bar every
night now the figure skating crew was in
the bar a lot and by far and away my
favorite rock star on and off the field
was Andrea Joyce tremendous lobbying up
at the park my injury is yours
Andrea Joyce first team all lobby bar
Johnny Weir can give you a run for your
money and hey we are white wine white
wine for Johnny we calmly thank you and
Jota Jota is sneaky-sneaky long they're
not just having a couple glasses with
all right fill us in on Tiger Woods how
excited should we be well this forever
and the clouds coming to this tournament
forever and this tournament I mean I
becoming it literally for however 10 12
15 years this tournament is always good
it's always well attended but yesterday
was a zoo and it was crazy how many
people are out here and it's all because
of one guy I've never seen anybody in
sports who the needle
here's a Hearst or like Tiger he's
leading right now he's at
apartheid to lead he's playing early
today so he won't be on television later
except for highlights but he's gonna put
himself in the mix for Sunday's Saturday
and Sunday run tomorrow afternoon and
it's it's gonna be crazy
crazy atmosphere right here finish this
sentence if Tiger wins this tournament
this weekend
he will vault himself like Phil did last
week into the discussion of top
favorites top four or five favorites at
Augusta in four weeks and you could
genuinely say that he is back for the
first time I don't think you can say
someone's back in the stature that Tiger
has put himself in on his resume the
last 20 years until he gets the win I
think he would say that too bad it's
nice to play well it's nice to put
yourself in contention it's a whole
nother thing to cross the finish line if
Tiger gets a win this week or next week
at Bay Hill before he goes to Augusta
you have to put him right there in the
mix as far as guys who are top favorites
to win the Masters and you could see
yesterday with reaction shots with Tiger
even if he didn't have a great shot that
that like I haven't seen him smile this
much in a long time and I know when you
talked to him afterwards you know he
it's almost like he realizes this is so
fleeting and I have it let's enjoy it as
much as I possibly can
that doesn't mean he turns off the
competitive light switch here but there
seems to be a little more joy in
Mudville here you spoken to in your
career on and off the air where they'll
tell you it you know you miss the
competition you miss the games but you
miss the guys the most you miss the
locker room the most now there's no
locker room atmosphere in golf
except when there's a long rain delay
but it's totally different than team
sports but what Tiger missed the most
was competing against the best man he is
either join the ride now you can look a
strong case then and he was the best
player of his era and one of the Great's
of all time because he was so focused
and and so singularly
you know hold in on trying to become the
greatest player in the world and that
perhaps if dialing it back and enjoying
the ride this time compared to last time
might you know hinder him in trying to
get back to becoming the best player in
the world but it's nice to see this he's
grown up he's a much different person
he's really more engaging with fans with
other players he's playing with with
with everybody in and around the game
and I don't think it's gonna hurt him
one bit as far as trying to get back
we'll see how focused he is when he's in
contention to see what he's like
Thursday and Friday banners you know
totally different than Saturday and
Sunday I'm curious to see if he is in
the leader in the one of the last couple
of groups you know how you reacts to
tomorrow
that's a big spot even for someone who's
done it a million times like he has
tomorrow is gonna be a very very big
spot if he's in one of the one of those
last couple of groups Paulie brought
this up let's fast-forward to the final
round at Augusta and let's say it's the
back nine and it's Phil and Tiger paired
who would America be rooting for you
know I've always thought in sports what
Jack was the greatest player of all time
Arnie was the most popular I've always
thought that the best players are not
the most popular because America roots
for your dog but in this case I think
Tiger is the underdog Tiger is the guy
who is making the comeback from all of
the things that happen to him away from
the golf course all of the health
injuries that happened to them while he
was competing for him to come back a
little bit of a softer Tiger coming back
being more engaged I think that Tiger
would be the reason that everybody is
watching
and I think Tiger would be more popular
of the two players in that particular
spot in four lakes but Man Alive would
that be something that those two oh my
and we had Phil on yesterday and he said
you know watch Tiger he's always one-up
me he goes you know I win watch him win
this weekend and then all of a sudden
Tiger goes out and puts himself in
contention so the last person who's
gonna be surprised at this is Phil
Mickelson without question in fact
Phil last week when one you know those
couple of minutes you get before guys
before you go live you almost get a
better deal with them for a couple of
minutes they do when you're actually on
the air Phil was talking about you know
coming back and and getting back in the
fray and being frazzled and being
nervous and his nerves being shot how
great it felt and all that kind of thing
so Tiger on either Tuesday or Wednesday
this week was asked about so now you
know that those two never really got
along when they were both at the top of
theirs at the top of the sport and at
the top of their games now it's a little
different just like Jack and Arnie they
got along much greater later in life and
they did when they were competing
against each other so Tiger said he was
inspired by watching Phil when he
thought it was great fulfill great for
the sport and great for him it gives him
a little bit more hope that you know it
at the advanced age although Phil is
five years older at the advanced age
once you get into your 40s it's so hard
to win then I think that Tiger has a
great appreciation for what Phil did
last week and I think it's going to help
him not just this week but moving
forward this year he's first team all
lobby bar no matter where that bar is
he's Steve since month ago don't you
love that I would say - John - the truth
hurts have fun there this weekend will
be what we want you thank you Steve
I know I didn't miss you
thank you Steve Steve Sands Golf Channel
NBC reporter play-by-play host for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]